στην κύπρο θα προσπαθείι εσι να μεταφέρει σ αυτά τα προβλή τους προβληματισμού στα παράπονα
θεσεωγικά ώστε το κοσιοκτώ να πάτε όλοι ι άθλητές απρόσκοπτα μόνος στο αθνημα σας και
να μισκεφτέστε τα προβλήματα ο καθένας για την ομοσπονδίατου ήτα οικονομικά σίγουρα θαπροσπάες α βοηθίζω
αλλά το πιο σημαντικό πιστεύο για ένα πρόταθλητεί που προσπαθεί νανα έρθει και να φέρει
ένα να αποτέλεσμα προβλήματα πάντοε α επάρχουν είναι να μηντα αφήνουν να των επηράσουν είνατην
επηράσουν και αυτό εντοσημαντίχν να μεν ει συγκετρονόες αυτόν που κάνεις στογός του προσηλωμένο στω
στων αγόνα σου και όλα αυτά ταπολικτικά προβλήματα σταμαμάσουμε μπορείς να προσπαθίσεις να τατιαρτόσει να
τααγνωρίζεις αν δεν τα καταφερισούμε για τις πιο πολλές φορές δεν θα καταφέρνεις γιατί σε
ένα ο περισοτέρος το χρόνος τον δίνεις στον άισε όσο πιο έτοιμος μπορίς και στον
απροπονίς ε αλλά πολλύ από τους παράγοντές ι εννιά τους είναι να δίνουν ολόν τους
το χρόνο απλά για να αποφελούντο αυτόν τους πο φελουν κάποιο πό τα συμφέροντα τος
και πολλές φορές όχι δεν βάζου το πρωταρχεικό συμφρον των αθλητών αλλά πρέπει ολί αυτή
να ξέρουν ότι ολός που είναι εκεί είναι κατί υπάρχει αθλητισμός αν δεν υπήρχαν αθλητές
της ιστειοπλοίας δεν θα επιχεινομοσπο ο δεν υπερχαναθλητές κοπηλασίας και ότι θα υπιχεέμε άρά πολλές
φορές χαννουμε το νόημα γιατί ολύ αυτεί η φορείς έχουν δημιοργηθεί και έγινε ενι ζωή
λόγοντου ότι ευπάρχουν αθλητές τώρα πώς είναι καθύμε όταν ενός ολημπιωνίκη υπάρχουν είναι έτσι δύο
ιδικά θημεροδάς το ένα είναι όταν ίμε την οικογί να μου και έχω και καθήκοντα
στις ζύγου και πατέρα η οποία κάθυμεροενότητα πολύς από το χρόνο δεν υπάρχει ελευτερο